today we're gonna be talking about the
single greatest time management tip I
ever received about law school outline
from day one so stick around and get an
edge in law school it's hard to
overstate just how important your
outline is in law school it's going to
be your primary studying device it's how
you distill all of your notes and your
cases in your commercial outlines into a
usable format specifically tailored just
for you but the kicker is that the
process of distilling everything takes
time and it takes way longer than you
think and time is the single greatest
equalizer in law school everyone has the
same amount and the students who get A's
are the ones that focus on what's
important and they cut out the time
wasters in other words they focus on the
stuff that actually helps on the final
exam now a good outline is necessary but
it's not sufficient to crush your final
the point of an outline is to study from
it to organize things in a logical way
so that you can study the crap out of
the things that are in your outline it's
a means to an end not an end itself now
this might seem like an obvious point
but I mention it because more than half
of my law school friends believe that it
was better to wait until the end of the
semester to start their outline because
they felt that they studied by making
the outline itself they thought that the
simple act of making their outline was
enough to study for their exam but this
is so wrong now sure the building of
your outline helps but it's only the
first step imagine if you were preparing
for a chess match by reading books about
the history of chess and you waited
until the week before the match to
actually memorize how the chess pieces
move it would be much better to have
memorize that stuff way ahead of time
and practice before your match and the
same as in law school better to have
your outline done months before your
final exam instead of wasting your
precious
I'm compiling your outline then as
finals approach you can practice by
applying the information that you
already put in your outline what most
students don't understand about their
outline is that more is not better
there's an old phrase that if I had more
time I would have written a shorter
letter the same is true for outlines it
takes time to distill all of that
information for a particular class and
to get it into a short usable form
ideally believe it or not I would say
the best outline is less than 20 pages
some people try to fit everything their
professor has ever said in a class into
their outline but this is the exact
opposite of what you should do the
longer your outline is the harder it is
to use and law school exams are all
about the application your outline is
your tool bag you want it organized you
want it clean and you only want the
tools that are going to help you for the
job at hand in your tool bag for example
a good craftsman could probably build a
table with just three tools sure he
might be able to make it faster or
better with more tools but it's better
to have three tools that you know like
the back of your hand than to have a
hundred tools that you don't and it's
the same way with law school outlines
much better to know a smaller outline
intimately than a longer outline only
superficially but distilling all of that
information takes time and I'm not gonna
lie it's hard work make no mistake
distilling all of the information from
your class and commercial outlines and
from your peers into a short concise
summary is one of the hardest things
about law school but it's also
invaluable so do yourself a favor and
start from week one the most common
objection I hear is but I can't start my
outline because I need context I need to
wait until I see how the whole class
fits together before I start distilling
things down well I have bad news for you
you will never have the whole context
for a class and you'll always
have an excuse to put it off but you
have to act and just start doing it and
it seemed to Lev author of the Black
Swan wrote understanding how to act
under conditions of incomplete
information is the highest and most
urgent human pursuit amen to that
make your outline starting week one and
then revise it you can always go back
and you'll probably find that very
little of what you write during the
first week of class will be used on the
final you can always go back and revise
it you'll understand more as the
semester progresses but it is far easier
to revise as you go than it is to start
from scratch just a week before finals
do what the startups do build a beta
version and then iterate from there
here's what I suggest
Monday through Friday during the regular
semester consider it your job to listen
to the professor take good notes read
your commercial supplements and try and
understand as much as you can about the
class and then over the weekend distill
all of that information into an outline
no more than one page per class per week
if you can do that by the time finals
come around you'll be done with your
outline and you'll already be crushing
your practice exams it just takes a
little work every week it's a marathon
not a sprint
so start early be consistent and you'll
crush finals with a kick-ass outline
that you started writing back in the
first week of the semester oh and by the
way if you want to get better grades on
your next law school final check this
out we've put together a free ebook
called the ultimate guide to crushing
law school files just click the link
below to download you'll show you
exactly how to prepare for your next
final including how to plan how to
outline and how to study for your next
file just click below also if you liked
this video please subscribe to our
Channel we come out with new videos on
how to crush law school all the time so
thanks from everyone here at legal eagle
[Music]